all right check check check we are we
can hear it we can do it
we got the vibe baby we got that vibe
that attitude they used to call it
attitude and I'll take them drinks right
there got me a couple beautiful
beverages right here coming in right now
premature Nick showing up early with
these beds boy shut up Nick that Iggy
Azalea huh Oh
oh my god this guy's lost his mind
this guy has lost his mind
yeah I got me sorry I got out of give me
a couple nights beverages right here and
I got that green machine or some
whatever they call it and I got the
brown went to with the protein in and
i'm bevvan so if you hear somebody
slither up and over here or somebody
catching a dram or somebody just adding
to their own human drip over here that's
me that is me oh man I can't do when my
heaven now my heaven used to be
different my idea of heaven my idea of
heaven used to be different
and first let me just let you know where
we are this past weekend and thank you
guys for joining us here I'm Theo von
and I'm part of this past weekend and
when I was young did my heaven now when
I was young heaven was different I
thought oh you go to heaven the first
thing I thought about honestly was the
food I thought about the food because
you know if I'm going all of that way
and I'm dying to even get into the joint
they better have some entrees you're
fair man
they better have a couple soup du jour
z' and douche mine maybe we all better
be having soup
and that's the first thing I thought
about when I was a child when I thought
about heaven I thought oh man they gonna
have all the different you know you have
a breakfast item right here and you have
a little over there you got an extra
chocolate area if you want to run
through there and get some chocolate or
do that or whatever you know I just
thought they have spare rib that kind of
stuff I've never even had spare rib but
I'd heard about it and sometime if you
met like a rich man or something like
that when you were young and you smelled
his breath you might catch that hit of
SR off that bad boy I'm talking my spare
rib and you get that just oh okay
I see what y'all doing at home you know
I got a little bit of cash at the house
but that's what I thought about heaven
when I thought about heaven when I was a
child my heaven had all kind of they had
food they had a big table with food on
it and then what else sorry they had a
lot of clouds I remember my heaven it
was a cloudy heaven like and not like I
guess not like 70% chance of rain or
anything like that or it was overcast
but fluffy that was my idea of heaven it
was overcast but fluffy and kind of warm
like probably clouds that were maybe you
know 400 count or 200 count or at least
80 count
I got some pillows at home that these
bastards probably about four count you
can feel the the quills from the UM I
don't even know what animal it was it
said it was goose but I bet it's I bet
it's a little bit more of a Warbler it
seemed like they plucked about two
thousand Warblers and threw these these
feathers into them pillow but every you
got a if you lay in one position then
that quill comes out and get you you got
a turn it's like oh man right then no no
no and finally you get in the right spot
and with no quills and that's when
you're like aw hell yeah hmmm well now
we living now we're living just laying
in the Lord's lap baby when you get that
nice comfortable pillow I can't believe
people don't have pillows installed
around our head or neck people get
tattoos all the time oh that's that
ain't comfortable you just you see
somebody with a tattoo it's nice its
artistic its drawing but it isn't uh you
know it's not it's not comfortable if I
saw somebody got a pillow so sewn into
the back of their head camera boy I'd be
right look I would understand it I say
oh yeah I see what you doing there that
wish you just got that big just that
that way anyway somebody even if you
fall down you had that nothing stay down
you trip over something stay down you
eat now you're napping there's
definitely a beauty I think of uh you
know I think there's just gonna be new
things we're gonna start doing in the
future that we're not doing yet where
we're taking care you know you know so a
pillow to your head or you know add
maybe some piping or something on the
outside of our knees and legs to give us
a more sturdy because people aren't that
sturdy
run and push someone I bet you they fall
over nine out of ten times if you run
and push somebody that batch is going
down but then change your game up change
your vibe up if the if they if they got
you know a couple of pieces of PVC pipe
hooked on each leg baby who knows what
could happen
it might take you a half hour to really
bring him down to the ground so anyway
just kind of but but what was your idea
of heaven when you were young you know
what was it and what is it now that's
what I think now my idea of heaven no
emails no emails no smart phones just
dumb phones remember - dumb phone do you
remember the dumb phone you did go over
- it was making a loud noise you did
pick it up and somebody would ask they
got to ask for one person this is a
rendered er no and you can lie here lie
so easily you could even if you were
Randi you could be like Randi ain't here
oh you got the wrong number we don't
even have a random right now let me see
if Randy is here Randy nope being here
I'm gonna happen man with the dumb phone
you could anything the dumb phone and
also if you if you answer you didn't
want to talk somebody you could wrap the
cord it had a cord you could wrap the
cord around your neck tyo al bruh take
your own life right there do you like
damn man what happened to Burt
you know I well somebody called he
couldn't handle it and now he's in
heaven but yeah that's my heaven no
email dumb phones only and what else
still food and I'm thinking now more
nachos more Chicken Picatta
maybe um where else what else would I
have definitely still the deserts but
more of like I would go with a coconut
when I was young it could be anything
just sugar it could be a table full of
sugar I don't even care just let me
stick my head in it for about 19 seconds
you know I don't even care I don't even
I don't care if they just put a bunch of
Laffy Taffy under my tongue and punched
me right in the mouth you know when
you're young you don't care but now when
I'm older I want my heaven to be a
little bit more I don't know I guess I
just want different things in it I want
you know I definitely want a live one a
lot of people there and but honestly
dude if somebody's real chatty you could
deh number I'll put them in a different
heaven because I when I go to heaven
noon I ain't doing a ton of listening
okay I want a quiet heaven so if you
don't want to get a different heaven if
they got kind of a more urban heaven or
something y'all can do that but my I'm
staying in that low just kind of mild
maybe a breeze the loudest thing is a
breeze you know maybe a breeze that
could sing so it's just kind of lonely
teardrops you know a breeze that kind of
just had could also you know yeah you
got that yeah yeah
the branches green beside me like I
don't want anything real loud in my
heaven but we'll see man and I want the
joy there too I want everything to be
Joy's I probably won't even be able to
judge when I'm in heaven now there won't
be as much judgement gosh that would be
nice to have less judgement imagine
somebody's just imagined that that would
be really just the biggest piece in mind
and my whole heart and brain if there
was less judgement inside of me because
if you crack me open dude you got about
a thousand Judy's fall out bro cuz I'm
judge mint I'm judge mint bruh I'm dude
if you saw me at a flavor fry scream I'm
judgmental [ __ ] chip Papa I just it's
hard not to judge sometime you know it's
hard but but also the judgment of me
allowed me to be able to do stand-up
comedy and do comedies so there's you
know it's as double swordman but but
yeah what was your heaven like now do
you have a different heaven and now I
think more there is when you're a kid a
heaven is just they got animals there
but you could pet him more I think they
have alligators but they're not
dangerous you might see alligator and
he's you know if you ask him if he's
ever eaten like human he would he would
tell you but he would he wouldn't just
tell you in front of everybody he would
kind of whisper to you later or kind of
write it on a you know maybe you know on
a napkin or something or something give
it slip it to you say yeah I've had a
little bit of you know you know I'm
saying I've had a couple vietze about a
river you feel me I've had a couple ah a
couple bad batches came down by the
water and I was on ground but I think
you know it's just different now because
what am I talking about I don't know um
but yeah if you have it what was your
head did you have a different heaven
when you were young as to what your
heaven idea is now you know now my
heaven has more like loved ones in it
it's not just about what I want it's
more I think about a little bit of you
know there's other people I want to make
sure everybody you know gets in you know
it's like I don't know anyway if you
ever thought on what your heaven was
like as a child maybe if you had an idea
of heaven
and if what it's like now and some
people you don't believe in heaven
that's fine you got here working just
kind of milling around maybe that's it
doesn't sound fun to me I like more of
like a you know that's all riiii-- I'm a
romantic you know I'm a romantic so but
what else just got off the road meant
tired and I am tired and I'm sometimes I
pretend I'm not tired dog I'm tired I'm
tired I could use somebody to just
stitch a real big a spillover to the
back of my head son that'd be nice
wouldn't it but I think we'll see that
as the future goes along we'll see more
accoutrement that are built onto us to
help us live through the daily day
because it's amazing we still have to
wear like a SPF to fight the Sun you
would think that they would have some
sort of an enzyme or something we could
just put right into us an injectable or
even if like a spare layer of skin we
could just kind of roll on you know or
dip ourselves in once a year like what
you get for Christmas all I got dipped
you know so okay so no sunblock for you
you could just do whatever you want yeah
you know you know but then all the
ladies will be like they only want to
date guys that have been dipped and they
don't want to see some poor goddess
rubbing
you know doing it the old way just
laying that just that human drywall
cream that SPF you know it would be
different I don't know what I'm talking
about
but I never have boy gang thank
everybody that came out to this weekend
we had a great time traveling over there
on the eastern side and and where did we
go man oh we went to oxen Hill no we
went to Red Bank New Jersey and man we
had such a time yeah we had such a time
there in Red Bank in Jersey you got they
got everything of it they got you see
you get the whole they got that mafioso
kind of vibe milling around you know you
could easily see I'm having some
smoothie bro this is good huh damn man
I'm having a lot right now I think they
always gonna have it as much but I need
it I guess I needed it I wouldn't had it
have some of this green drink yeah but
if you have maybe if you never notice if
you had a certain idea of heaven when
you were young
hit the hotline nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and drop me
some verbal and let me know if you
thought about yeah
see in my heaven no more of that we
won't be having all of that yeah we went
over there Red Bank New Jersey and that
show had originally been over for
Sayre's Ville where people say stuff and
and that you know and that's what they
do but this at Red Bank was it was good
man we came out with that hot hit right
out the gate and we had we had a young
fella brought out a single mom Maria we
brought her out I'm gonna do some do
something nice for her so that was
really great widows well I had a friend
of mine Britney brought out her fiance
and her whole family and they came out
and she brought her mother out and um
you know just some good Jersey people a
lot of you know a little bit of cheetah
print some perfume uh you know kind of
stuff make you really made me feel real
v rile you you know make you feel real
veeraiah but I make a lot of your blood
kind of crawl in here you know when your
extremities brah
you know what I'm saying so just really
nice it was nice a lot of just great
people I want to thank everybody that
came to that show that was that hard
hitter and and do it if in the winter if
you go through like when you're driving
along through like New Jersey and all of
that a lot of the woods and stuff
there's a lot of factories and woods
so you could see a factory like Oh what
are they making and the guys like all
that we make socks over there that's a
sock plant
I think Danielle and their makers socks
it's crazy
cuz you see these guys they're all tough
and sweaty and this and then like I'm
what's going on you know not that my
what are you doing nothing but but then
you find out they're making socks that
kind of like damn what y'all doing in
you know dear but you know much respect
meant a lot of sock makers out there
that's it's you know it's it not anybody
could do it I guess but yeah you see you
know different they got smoke coming out
and all they got a lot of plants they
got petroleum over there they got guys
making salve and making them you know
what else what other plant did we find
somebody that worked at a jam factory
making jams and jellies I say huh and
this dude was so skinny to the guy I met
he working over there for Schmucker or
whatever or some bootleg jam company you
know some off-brand jam you know shinies
jam you know or SPARC is jelly you know
or robear's sweet spread you know some
guy working over there some halfway
house jam outfit where they probably got
you know 12-step meetings in the evening
but yeah you know that it's had
different factories and people came out
so a lot of beautiful good people came
over Derrida to Red Bank and next we had
a call that came in about it let me hear
that here we go gang hey Theo this is
Otto guys from Minneapolis
what's up Bora guess and that's our that
is a very special name or gasps it
sounds like something out of the the
Greek
you know or a gas you know we've had we
used have to go he lived on the mountain
and we had to go up there to get a bag
of lightning from him or something or
get a couple grams of our olives or
whatever you know what I'm talking about
fables fable REE let's hear more or gasp
thank you for calling in Minneapolis
there have been a Minneapolis man but
it's a good place a lot of fish out
there a lot of lakes and it used to be a
big lake but it dried up so now they
have a bunch of tons of little lakes so
you have a lot of fish that got
displaced from their families because
they were swimming over here looking for
something and then the late things dried
up and now you know I'm saying they'll
never see their grandfather so if you
put your ear up to the water of it you
can really hear a lot of the it's almost
like a swan you know you can hear a
little bit of the sadness of uh just
kind of what's occurred there amongst
those oh those water critters let's hear
more brother homeward I saw your
February 27th show in Red Bank New
Jersey with my best friend he and I made
an agreement a long time ago that we
would see our favorite comedian together
one of the member has shown you're one
of us okay
so that's a unique agreement to a lot of
men don't make an agreement like that I
don't think if we're gonna see a we
would see a show if he was near us and
we would see a show if he came near us
let's hear it after a lot of grinding we
were finally financially stable enough
to do that but flew I have to meet him
in the flesh for the second time and to
see the show I loved every second of
that [ __ ]
wait hold me here one part again you met
him getting the flesh for the second
time so you met him in the flesh for the
second time it's your best friend you
said buddy so dang what do so I'm
thinking how do you if you don't I mean
I guess you can have a best friend you
don't know you know you could have a
best friend you don't know that's a
unique way to do it that's a special
you know that's like almost like I guess
it's like believing in ghosts or
something hey you got to meet my friend
Todd I haven't met him but that'll mean
[ __ ] you feel me as you could do that
hey you gotta meet Gary bruh I don't
know him but no man I'm glad you guys
were able to piece this together and I'm
glad I could be that glue I'm glad I
could be that secret sauce that brings a
couple of mystery bad boys together the
flesh for the second time and see your
show I loved every second of that [ __ ]
we sat third row and last the whole time
and we definitely enjoyed that kick-ass
booty who's sick loved it but uh thank
you for an amazing night out with a
friend and thank you for all the dark
holes here soft voice and magical night
whoa daddy thank you brother thank you
thank you for calling and this sounds
like a um you know this sounds real
homoerotic brother to be honest with you
at the end and I'm not really I'm not
judging you but I'm definitely saying
that it's super obvious if you're not a
gay man then you're surprised you're
probably surprising a lot of people
because people a lot of people probably
think you are that you love men and you
are a man which is fine man you know I
don't even think I mean a lot of women
are making it you know it's damn this
your best friend did it sound like y'all
are lovers but uh buddy it sounds like
you guys are sexual men and that's you
know that's something it's a way it hey
look there's more than two ways to
frickin feel a a falcon you feel me
so if you had to get if you get out
there within another man especially in
Minneapolis it's cold out there
sometimes it get so cold
eyes freeze you don't know who you who
you [ __ ] might be [ __ ] somebody
for a couple months and then your eyes
stall out you're like damn what's going
on Christopher
so but um I'm glad you guys were able to
make it buddy
I'm glad you're able to make it boy
that's important and I'm gonna look
honestly dude if two men want to meet up
and [ __ ] after my show dude they can do
it they can do it you know you don't
want to do that you don't want to be
wild and stuff like that and cut the
lamps off or maybe leave one lamp on so
you could still see some of that ass
meat brother and do what you got to do
but do what you got to do Bradley do
what you got to do Ernesto
you know I don't care do what you got to
do you don't want to do that do it do we
do we do it
so have fun man I'm glad you guys had a
good time I'm glad you guys had a good
time man amen brother praise God all
right man let's hit one more call that
came in what's up Derek over there out
of Richmond and Richmond is a lot of
presidents buried there more presidents
buried in Richmond than anywhere else in
America over there at the Hollywood
cemetery I believe and I went there one
time actually probably seven years ago
or something with a comedian and he was
an herb urban fella and he got a bit by
a dog there on the property so let's
hear more I'm leaving DC right now just
saw at the MGM last night and man whoo
okay let's hear more it was such a great
show so much fun my girlfriend got me
two tickets for Christmas and I've just
been looking forward to it all weekend
and he killed it it was so much so much
fun I laughed the whole entire time my
girlfriend was laughing the whole time
even afterwards went in there to take a
piss and me and all these random
or just your holding our dicks and
pissing them some porcelain and just
talking about how great the show is and
how much we love you to just keep it up
man everything you're doing
it's great dang man what is going on man
I think our audience is changing I got
uh uh yeah yes yes yes yes yes man thank
you so much for coming out dude
and look I to be honest man that the MGM
show was tough you know the security at
the venue was lackluster I felt like one
of the security guard people were
hitting me messages later said that he
was asleep by the stage so you know it
was a big just a you know there was just
a lot of them I mean this guy was just a
lot of running backs you know a lot of
skill position players and this guy
that's just bad security man so that was
a and it was are easily savers show the
opener Ari manis he said of all the
places we've ever been that was his
least favorite or not least favorite
show but least favorite experience but
um but yeah I just felt back as if the
people at the front were so loud there
was some guy who is a complete alcoholic
that really wrecked a lot of the show
this real selfish dude about a front
honestly and I know I'm gonna you know
but [ __ ] that dude also you know like
kind of like mono maybe I should but
also [ __ ] the guy because he just
yelling [ __ ] the whole time you know it
wasn't about me he was making it about
him and and that was just a tough one
for me man but and it was just the venue
it was so like if and it was some some
guy in the front dressed like a wolf of
wallstreet like though no like american
like christian bale's
in what is it it's not Tuck Everlasting
what does that move he was in where he
throws a liquor on the lady in the
bathtub and he's a murderer
American new Erica gangster no what is
that American something but yeah this I
just they had two extremely drunk women
in the fridge it was what it was look
man it was what it was that's what it
was but what's important is I I felt
like everybody in the back had a blast
and the people right in the front it was
really hard for them to stay involved
but yeah man look we I gave it my all on
that show I broke out everything I had I
gave him all I was fighting to keep it
up but it's just tough sometime at the
venue when you got a police the crowd so
much and you then you can't focus on
your on doing that being entertaining
and but I'm glad you had fun man I'm
glad you and them fellas was in there
holding y'all's meet em I'm just talking
about me I guess man this had this
episode we really maybe everybody's gay
bruh you know maybe everybody's gay dude
I don't know man but and look I think
it's
like Minneapolis it gets cold enough man
that's not gay really that's how cold is
it if it's two degrees and Steven and
Wallace suddenly are having sex are they
gay men or are they doing their best
because it's cold you know I'm saying
you have to everything comes into
account but that was very sweet of your
girl to get you this tickets and I'm
glad that you had a great time man I had
a great time I just always I want it to
be the best and and it just the staff at
the venue that just wasn't honestly I
thought they did a shitty job I didn't
think they did their job so gang [ __ ]
bruh oh right we got a patreon question
came in right here but first let me tell
you about better help this episode is
brought to you by better help better
help will assess your needs and match
you with your own licensed professional
therapist you can start communicating in
under 24 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online and sometimes we all
need help you know we all need help
sometimes you know it's funny my mother
texted me the other day and she said
that's what she just kind of said we'd
been having a conversation about stuff
and she said we you know we all need
help sometimes and man it just really
that really resonated with me we really
do and better help is an opportunity if
you don't have therapy or counseling in
your area or you afraid to go see one
you think it's lame you think is gay bro
you think it's this or that then this is
an option it's online it's on the phone
it's over FaceTime it's not a crisis
line it's professional counseling you
can log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor it's
available worldwide it's committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed
better help wants you to start living a
happier life today visit better help
calm slash Theo that's better
h LP and join the over half a million
people taking charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for this past
weekend listeners get 10% off your first
month at better help calm slash Theo and
this episode is brought to you by better
help oh yeah yeah we all need help
sometimes yeah
I think it's easier to get help but it's
hard to like it to say to say it almost
sometimes it's hard to say I need help
you know there's a story about they had
this man Ronald auktioner I think was
his name and there's a hospital down in
New Orleans called ochsner and they
spell it some way that that's impossible
that you would ever know how to
pronounce it unless somebody told you
but then that's vintage Louisiana and
I'm saying that's why Louisiana is so
special because if you want to know
something about it some of the words and
this and that are so confusing you got
to hear it firsthand from somebody and
that's what makes it a community effort
that's what gives it that vibe is
there's so much mystery hidden in the
way that they put the wording together
that um you have to have somebody
explain it to you or somebody to be
there to help you experience it and
that's what gives it its core really of
connection and tourism and stuff like
that that you find there Louisiana but
this man Ron Ochsner he was a doctor
famous doctor like if you saw somebody
that was doing well they're like wow man
how are you doing so well say well I
went to see him ron Ochsner and he
started a hospital and he was like the
smartest doctor he was like the smartest
doctor around and one day he was at a
convention and they
servin aam they had on London broil as
the premier meet at the I thought at the
function luncheon functional unction the
luncheon and he was choking he started
choking on it he started choking on a
piece of that broil you know just had
hot just a hot tri-tip was just really
really trying him and and he went in the
bathroom and choked to death at a
convention of doctors because he was too
embarrassed to check in and see what was
up he was too embarrassed to just say to
somebody else I so he died in the
bathroom he choked to death but just a
reminder that yeah sometime we need help
and sometimes the hardest part is to ask
for it like if somebody would have
walked in on him and seen him struggling
he just said yeah I need help but to go
out and present yourself as something
that is not part that's imperfect or
that isn't perfect you know that's the
that's really the that's one of the real
toughest points it's just that just
surrendering you saying yes help me you
know I can't I need air I need this I
need love I need peace I need vision I
can't see from us I can't
whatever I'm seeing isn't clear
something's wrong I need help but anyway
that's what's going on we got a patron
question from Joey Piemonte and I know
he does hangover candle company and
they've supplied us with so many candles
and I want to say thank you Joey for
those beautiful
and he said Theo you stay so busy and
give us so much content when is there a
bit of extra time just for yourself do
you have any hobbies well honestly I
wasn't even going to do this episode
today I was going to just chill and we
came in because we didn't we didn't we
didn't need it for ads because we have a
guest episode this week with the Krista
Stefano tomorrow and TJ Miller coming up
so if you have any questions for those
guys hit the hotline or send us a video
through the website a video question or
you can hit up real Nick Davis on
Instagram and ask him how to send a
video question for either one of those
guys you know what I just started doing
I started reading more I'm gonna try to
focus more on my AAA program now that I
have now that a lot of the big touring
is over
I started playing chess the other day on
my computer actually not the other day
maybe about two weeks ago and I liked it
it's just me against the computer and
it's just regular level but I like it
you know I like just I want my brain to
think about other stuff then then work
and so those are things that I'm doing
you know I'm going to Maui this weekend
to do a show and then I'm gonna relax
and work on meditation and go to some
AAA meetings and uh yeah I just
sometimes it's like you you and I don't
think of it as giving myself but you
yeah there's so much output that I don't
even know what's going on inside of
myself sometimes um so I want to do some
kind of just human accounting and
balance the books inside of myself a
little and I hope to focus on a little
bit of that more as the future comes
along soon now
another question we have here
Michelle Mildred from patreon said do
you have bougie requests for snacks or
decor in your green room if not if you
could have a dream green room setup what
would be in there like if you were an
insanely big rock band like the stones
are like Chris D'Elia
what would you require to be in there
before you go to your green room money
is no object well I don't know if I
would you here well crystal Lea that
probably it's easy for him to have
whatever he wants in his green room
because he was born in a green room you
don't know that about him when he was
born there was everything there snacks
Oh little pictures of milk and different
types of milk you know oh you want some
cut of cheeses I'll use a newborn who
cares here's half a handful of brie cuz
that's how Chris is oh oh yeah hey when
he came into the world somebody said he
came out of a couple of vaginas that's
how you know cuz them fancy boys that's
how they present them to the world they
come out of one vagina and then another
one another when it's just big and then
another vagina says a trumpet in it it's
just playing a trumpet but you know me
boy I had a freaking elbow crawl dude I
had elbow crawl and that was it bright
they had half a Winston on the way out
of my mother son that's how I came out
the wasn't in the white nobody there
weren't even a doctor out there my mom
was at work when I was born she said
well go on home I'll meet you home I'll
meet y'all then what she said pick up
something if you want stop by the
Popeyes getting a fight with a big
sister if you know if you need whatever
you need get a two-piece and getting a
fight with somebody get your arm stuck
on somebody's weave do what you got to
do fam I said so I learned to walk out
of necessity
but yeah in different green rooms
different things I have simple stuff in
mine I having something a little bit of
berries in there raspberry or blueberry
or blackberry and I have some sliced
turkey on a plate and that's what I'll
light and coffee but I think I might be
allergic to coffee so I mean I'm gonna
back off of that but that's it that's
that those are the things that I have oh
yeah I wasn't even do this episode but
honest I'm not even joking the reason I
did was because I this is what we do you
know sometime we don't want to show up
and we show up you know Stu knows we
don't want to show up but we show up and
I honestly I feel better now than when I
was uncertain if I wanted to or not to
do the episode let's take a call off of
this one here we go the hotline is
always nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three yeah what else do
support bubbler from Orange County
bubbler from The OC huh hmm and we used
to have a fellow boss growing up named
Bubba Jenkins and his brother drove a
bush light truck and bubby was real he
had a real he was real edgy he was real
edgy as a child we're all edgy in our in
our neighborhood I mean I'm surprised if
you two tested our neighborhood for a
cliff or a steep embankment or drop-off
nearby we de tested positive because we
was on edge baby we was edgy and Moby
had a low basketball goal buys house
when we go there and dunk on it mm-hmm
and we would dunk on each other and then
everybody would just end up beating the
[ __ ] out of each other just because you
know fouls and everything and just being
poor but anyway what you got playboy
Bubba I'm just wondering what your
thoughts on this virus probe you think
it's coming for you you got you doing it
precautions take care of yourself I just
want to know what you got that
coronavirus a bit kovin
19 wonder if you guys know or not but
the primate center that I grew up around
and Covington Lousiana
and why you know they had us out there
wrangling chimps and when I was probably
I don't even know just I don't even know
how tall or what maybe titty high on a
middle-aged woman you know top of the
titty but you know uh they gave that
same Center where monkeys escaped in my
hometown growing up they gave them forty
million dollars to fight this virus or
to try and cure it dude I'm telling you
this man in my town bar they ain't
curing [ __ ] man you know what I'm saying
no doubt I'm not saying but look they
got a Popeye's four blocks from the
freaking primate Center they nobody's
curing [ __ ] around there am i saying
they're not doing a decent job or this
or that or they're not going to test and
do the tests and stuff but look if you
come down by the Tchefuncte River and
you expect us to solve it all save the
world we're not doing that we don't do
that we want the monkeys to have a
little fun we want everybody to flare up
a little we doing Mardi Gras we doing
recipes we saw ween doing all of the
[ __ ] saving everybody that's not us
somebody has to go somebody has to go to
heaven somebody has to go to hell we the
would we I grew up in us in the stray
animal belt I grew up in this and in a
area where the number one currency is is
anecdotes and stories and memories you
know that's that's the vibe of Louisiana
it's about the it's about the fun and
about the the mystery it's
that's what you get around us so you
come down and you can pump 200 billion
you could put a villian dollars in 200
billion baby or 1 billion and look I'm
telling you being better all just buying
you a a dozen a fresh oyster with a
little bit of bread pudding dessert and
calling it a wrap Sun and save you money
and save you money too but what do I
think about the coronavirus here's what
I think I think I think we'll never know
right now how real things are how real
things aren't I don't believe you could
trust I do not believe you could trust
news out of China I do not believe that
you could trust mainstream media to to
tell you anything that doesn't have some
other side of it for them or you know
they want they want to scare us because
they can sell ads they keep us glued to
their television you know I think it's
always a good idea to take care of
yourself you know it seems like it
sounds like the cold it sounds like the
flu and it doesn't seem like
statistically compared to bigger does
compared to other diseases to that it's
really doing anything you know you could
die of anything now and you could just
say it's Quran emits it sound like the
Vegas [ __ ] I've ever heard but it just
sounds real popularized you know it's
like there's always been you know swine
flu there was SARS remember all of this
nobody nothing nobody ever none of that
[ __ ] did anything nobody knows anybody
died from SARS what no some people
thought it was a test one guy took it
now he's an attorney out there I was how
to Folsom over there in Livingston
Parish Louisiana so it's hit or miss but
this is a Miss I think for me I just
don't now do I think that
I think it's a perfect I think this is a
perfect example for us to see the power
of the media and how much they can scare
people and we're just at a time now
where people don't believe the news
anymore rightfully so and they shouldn't
and it's a great time to take care of
yourself and take care of your own and
trust your instincts you know the number
one news source that most of us have I
think is our instincts I mean sometimes
it's hard to read them but but that's
okay if something bad if you get them
wrong you get the instincts wrong you
read them wrong and you mess up then
that's why you got to be a good person
because then you go to heaven baby and
then they got what you want up there
they got the snack table baby they got
unlimited videos they got it all okay
let's take another call that came in
right here nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three okay see oh this is
the Johnny from Rhode Island I had a
quick question for you
feel a little weird about this one but
whatever so I'm 26 years old my cousin's
21 years old in college and I'm not
gonna lie she's pretty good-looking girl
she's been posting pictures on Instagram
you know I haven't really seen her that
much since she's gotten older and oh if
you've never even seen her then she
could be your best friend according our
previous caller homework she looks
pretty good
her family's got a beach house right
near my father's and you know she she
invited me to come with her friends out
to the beach this summer and hang out
with them is it weird if I go should I
bring some of my friends I mean I don't
want to be staring at her I don't want
to do something stupid if we get you
know a little drunk or whatever so now
tell me what what I should do so I
hooked my friends up I don't know you
know but
oh I could tell since it was the last
thing you offered it the last suggestion
you have is to hook your friends up so I
know you're taking that off the table
look I think you love your cousin I
think you're attracted to her I think
yeah I don't even know if it if it's
illegal anymore to be in love with your
cousin is it illegal hold on hold on
Johnny sexual relations between first
cousins are illegal in Mississippi I
know Johnny right now I start was your
name Johnny the mixer Johnny near Casey
oh this is uh Johnny from Rhode Island
yeah Johnny
yeah Johnny I know right now you are
hoping that your state doesn't come on
this list sexual relations between first
cousins are illegal in Mississippi thank
God
Kentucky mm-hmm Texas Wisconsin North
Dakota South Dakota and Nevada
they're unregulated but generally
frowned upon in all other states
generally frowned upon so that could be
anything
Washington DC and territories those are
other places where they're unregulated
but generally frowned upon look man you
know love is love man you know the guy
called from after oxen Hill show DC and
he's holding his weiner in there with
other men and they enjoyed the show
that's less some cup that's some type of
love dude it's not you know it's the
other guy never even met the dude they
came up together and you know and they
met for the second time or whatever
they're best friends or whatever and
they are obviously lovers and gay men
but that's love so if you wanna I
here's the thing you don't he what you
don't want to do is seem like a pervert
you don't want to go out there and be
perving out on your cousin if she's not
returning the vibe bro that's a no cuz
that's your cousin that's your real
cousin you can have to see here at
future events and [ __ ] you can't pop a
couple Molly and roll over there to the
UM family reunion is [ __ ] man you can't
or do you want to be that dope ass
cousin years from now that tried to hook
up with the hot cousin in the family I
would just say I would I would look at
the future five years from now say
you're at a family reunion what does
this look like if I do it now and take
the vibe from her to spend the bottle
with her and her friends see if they
make it so there's no chant like okay
you know Larissa can't spin if John here
or something
if she does that you know you got a you
know got to think outside the box dude
because if you think inside the box too
much you could have a baby that has you
know too much legs so you got to stay
classy brother but at the same time if
somebody gets divorced y'all might not
even be cousins anymore so you also need
you know love is love brother
love is love but but so I would go to
the beach I would bring a friend but
there's nothing wrong with lusting after
a cousin there's nothing wrong with that
it's just how you proceed through it
that's where it thinks he'd get unique I
used to date a girl and her cousin was
in newer now that I think about it her
male cousin she had a cousin a male
cousin who loved her who was into her
and who we try hitting on her and she
thought it was so [ __ ] up she just
always thought it was kind of weird
they're still friends are still good
buddies and cousins but she always
thought it was a little strange so
anyway that's just like a little view
from the other side of the tracks
what else we got here that came through
Oh we'll get we get last week we talked
about was there anything in your life
that you let go of that you wish you
hadn't
and people hit the hotline with a couple
of thoughts on that and uh let's get to
those right now
Yvonne what is that my brother this is
that coming from the other coast all the
way on the side of the country
in North Carolina what's up Jack from
the NC in North Carolina is a it's quite
a real secretive and unique area and
people love it there you know people
always talk about the Outer Banks and
the inner banks and uh you know Wells
Fargo all of the [ __ ] over there people
love it gang
just like in practice said hit the
hotline if you had something good and
you just gave it away like dude I
remember back in high school I did like
I was able to really it seemed like get
any girlfriend I want yeah
and imagine what that's like but you
know everybody has a time in their life
where they're a champ you need to get
that champ earlier you get that champ
late but everybody has that time to be
that to that chirpin champ we all get it
there's some there's some moment in the
war because and here's the thing if you
chirp early you don't chirp late
sometimes you know but everybody has
that everybody has that chance to be a
chirp and champ let's hear more had a
lot of good girls and dude I would
always just give them up I'd always
break up with them because I always just
wanted another one like I wanted a a
better looking winner I wanted a funnier
one and like you know I've really
struggled to even like get in a
relationship nowadays I'm 26 years old
been a while since I have like an actual
girlfriend and I don't know man I just
think it's kind of funny it's like I
don't know what part of me is always
just like doesn't want to accept this
ding and like always think there's
something better you know strict maybe
there is maybe there is a reason you
know I'll let them go and and maybe
something good is going to come down the
line but nonetheless it is just kind of
a interesting part of my ego as well
anyways appreciate you dude
I'll see you later Ganga and thank you
for the call man yeah it's you know we
always can be kind of hedging our bets
saying or not head or unhedged in them
you know we're always saying okay well
this situation is good but I'm willing
to put I'm willing to set it to the side
and see if another one comes you know
and then I think sometimes another one
might not come I mean you sound young
enough and I mean you are you're gonna
you're 26 you said but you sound wise
enough and aware enough where at least
you kind of see what's going on and you
you know uh at least you you're
self-aware you know so you're gonna it's
gonna fit it's gonna work out fine for
you brother because you know now you've
you're calibrated and you'll know okay
you'll know when what's right is right
comes next
but yeah it's interesting how there's a
part of us that's always like okay maybe
there's something better maybe there's
something different you know there's
always something different maybe there's
something better while we're not happy
while we're or maybe while we are happy
but we just we want to roll the dice
there's a great value in being able to
say I am happy and and to not have that
let temptation get you that's one of the
worst things about social media is just
this is always temptation there's always
advertising can reach us there's always
something telling us that we could be
different or better there's always some
chick running by in a bikini with you
know size eleven titties over there it's
a bit in a small feat you're like damn
but you don't see the aftermath when she
goes and sits out on her brother's truck
or whatever and she's shooting up or
she's you know vomiting out the back of
a van or something so she could take
fiducia
you know uh because she's all you know
you know twerked out on bang energy
drink and hasn't eaten in a month we
don't see the full role it's that
temptation but yet I recognize when
we're really happy inside of ourselves
there's a real value in that but you
have so you have you of other good
opportunities come along me sound like a
wise young felon and thank you for
sharing that experience yeah because
it's interesting it's like yeah you know
I've asked God for things in my life and
then he gives them to me
or the powers in the world give them to
me and I have them and then as soon as I
kind of have my say well maybe I'll go
back to the poker table one more time
you know and whatever that little battle
is right there that's man there's
something that's real strong it's
powerful to be able to say man I'm
grateful for what is this is and I'm
gonna take care of this gift that I have
and I know what dating and stuff I'm
kind of generalizing it you know but and
dating is just kind of specific thing
but yes you know it's the gambler man
that's the gambler okay Hideo my name is
Jennifer and I just heard your podcast
about how sometimes it's difficult to
figure out you have something really
good and how are you can sometimes get
in the way and I wanted to share my
story and especially because I'm older
and in my early 50s and this happened
when I was in my early 20s thank you for
calling Jennifer and you know let's hear
about it so I wanted it to be a little
customary tale for the young folks that
listened to your podcast
I was dating a really wonderful man he
was my first love but he didn't make a
lot of money he was a lifeguard I met a
guy who oh yeah and you really named one
of the jobs probably the lowest
money-making job that there really is
almost besides somebody just walking
around looking for money and the second
one is just probably lifeguard let's
hear more thank you for the call who was
an investment banker and made a lot of
money spend a lot of money on me and so
long story short I dumped the lifeguard
thinking oh I've got it made with this
guy the new guy and he turned out to be
a major douche bag and I surprised and
when I went crawling back to the
lifeguard
he was already dating a professional
volleyball player and his attitude
toward me was pretty much talk to the
hand and to this day I regret having
done that so just FYI if you have
somebody good don't be so sure that
you've got a million more chances to
meet better and better people because
that doesn't happen too often and for in
my case I never found anyone I liked as
much as the lifeguard guide them thank
you love you I love your podcast mwah
big hugs gang thank you I love you too
and I appreciate that arm
appreciate you sharing that anecdote
from your life yes yeah I mean you know
they say you don't know how something
good something is till it's gone and but
yeah it's just so like we get gifts you
know sometimes and sometimes they're
people and sometimes they're things and
sometimes their experiences and but I
think the people one is most important
you know when you get that gift of being
able to know someone or or have that
time have someone's time have someone
care about you and it's nice you get to
care about somebody that's one thing
that I've really started to learn in the
past years in my life is just how much I
really enjoy caring about someone else
it's nice I mean it's really nice to
just have somebody to care about you
know make sure that somebody is taking
care of make sure that somebody is warm
and comfortable and make sure that
somebody is not scared you know make
sure that somebody is you just make sure
that somebody's loved you know make sure
that it's nice because when you when you
have somebody and and you get to do
those things for somebody and they
accept them and they and and and they
give them back to you that's a real that
they they don't advertise that but you
know that's something that comes from
the inside of us that the only advertise
only it's time you know when that's
really right is when you get that int
that that inner vert izing when your
heart tells you yeah this is something
there's something real over here but
thank you for sharing your tales and you
think you for sharing your thoughts and
thank you guys just for thank you guys
for everybody that came out this weekend
and we and we finished it up in Virginia
Beach and over know in Newport news or
bad news they call it
and uh but it was good news on that
night and somebody just I met so many
people wonderful people for the show
after the show I tried to meet as many
people as I could and if I didn't get to
meet you then I'll meet you next time
and those were the makeup shows so those
were the last of the makeup shows except
for Brea which I'll get to sometime this
year that uh I'm just gonna go over
there and work on new material a little
later in the year or in the summer or
something but but thanks for sticking
with me thanks for being a part of the
dark arts tour for checking it out and
and yeah it was just this this weekend
was so much fun it was so much fun and
I'm and I know a good thing you know and
that's why I showed up today because I
just I know a good thing and a good
thing that we have that I feel it and
have felt from everybody across this
entire country and really across the
whole world
in Australia and in the UK in Norway and
Sweden and somewhere else but it's just
that there's some there's a good energy
in here and and I hope to focus more on
that and work more on that and figure
out how we can start to do more good
things together and for others and gang
ruff all day thank you so much for the
love and support thank you
and we'll finish out a little bit of gun
right here
and we'll keep it a little bit you let's
do something fun with missile gun here
uh anything you want because I think
together man we figure it out together
we can have anything you want if you're
struggling out there keep your head up
you know if you're unmotivated just just
put the next foot in front of the other
you could do it you know if your brain
doesn't want to do something just move
your feet and your brain will follow I
know that it really will just get going
you know you can do it if you're
struggling with something you can do it
I know you can and don't be too hard on
yourself
I learned that from you guys alright man
let's get through it
be good to yourself gang
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
since when another man so soon
Oh
the approach to a reality
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with a bright night
[Applause]
[Music]
twenty-one years by the Black Hills
getting ready for the next thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]